la persona es persona desde el primer
momento de su vida cuando empieza la
vida
biológicamente sólo tenemos una célula
pero esa célula está pegada a algo
inmaterial ese algo inmaterial ese
corazón espiritual está pegado a la
célula primera desde el primer momento
de la vida y ese es el corazón
espiritual que mueve a esa célula ya
todas las demás células que tengamos en
nuestro cuerpo
ese corazón espiritual
está pegado a la célula y con palabras
con una palabra rara de el antropólogo
marcel yus está en tus excepción a da el
corazón espiritual de la persona
intercepción a la célula y las
siguientes células de nuestro cuerpo y
la y la utiliza claro es la base de
nuestra vida pero es la forma de
manifestarnos algo espiritual inmaterial
se manifiesta a través de la materia de
una biología como ha estudiado el
antropólogo marcel looze mediante los
gestos la persona es una una máquina de
hacer gestos cómo lo hace
que hay en ese corazón espiritual quien
lo forma en primer lugar un conocimiento
profundo
el conocimiento profundo y conocer es la
actividad vital más alta en la persona
la persona tiene muchas actividades
vitales la más alta es el conocer fuera
de la persona humana no hay nadie en el
cosmos que tenga interés por conocer la
persona así la persona tiene desde el
primer momento el intelecto agente hace
20 o 24 siglos que lo describió
aristóteles el intelecto agente está en
acto la inteligencia racional aparecerá
más tarde como potencia y la
inteligencia racional por la noche no
funciona el intelecto agente funciona
día y noche 365 días al año desde el
primer momento de la vida
y ese conocer profundo es otra forma de
conocer que nada tiene que ver con la
abstracción de las formas de la razón es
un conocimiento total y la persona tiene
ese conocimiento total desde el primer
momento de la vida
en ese momento conoce el entorno y ese
entorno lo ama si alguien quiere saber
lo que es el amor tiene que bajar a ese
momento a ese momento primigenio en que
es todo es conocer y amar y como lo hace
de una forma libre la libertad está ahí
la libertad está ahí en ese momento la
libertad de ese entorno que conoce la
criatura nueva él lo elige libremente a
la persona que quiere amar hay muchas
personas en el entorno y ella elige
libremente a quien ama a quien ama más a
quien ama menos todo eso son los
trascendentales de la persona descritos
por otro antropólogo este filosófico
leonardo polo de esos tres
trascendentales de la persona junto con
el hábito innato de sabiduría forman lo
que es el corazón de la persona cuando
hablamos del corazón espiritual hablamos
de esas tres trascendentales y hábito
innato de sabiduría sabiduría que tienen
todas las personas
da igual que luego se formen o que no se
forme da igual que luego vean a la
universidad o no vayan a la universidad
todos estamos dotados de sabiduría ese
saber profundo que supera todos los
saberes y ahora vosotros preguntan y
bueno y tú como sabes esto han dicho que
eres médico y efectivamente es así yo
acabé en medicina
y luego me especialicé en radiología y
practicaba la radiología durante 40 años
me he dedicado durante 40 años a hacer
radiología de la biología y hace 7 años
sucedió algo muy potente en mi persona
que me ha cambiado la vida y es el
descubrimiento de la palin genes ya que
es una forma de hacer introspección
antropológica profunda de la persona y
voy encontrando cosas que es lo que
encuentro que cualquier persona que
tenga una dolencia una alteración una
enfermedad un bloqueo un sinsentido
cuando haces una introspección y llegas
a esa parte primigenia esa persona que
ahora tiene 70 años o que tiene 40 o que
tiene 30 en un momento fue un corazón
un corazón virgen que llega a este mundo
con una célula a la cual into su
excepción y en ese momento es
precisamente en ese momento la persona
empieza a tomar decisiones libres la
libertad consiste en decir a quien das
tu amor y entonces y esto es
imprevisible empiezo a ver personas
adultas esa parte primigenia que toma
que toma decisiones y toma decisiones
imprevisibles siempre y la única forma
de saberlo es revivir esos momentos esos
momentos esas decisiones que toman en
ese momento le van a le van a
condicionar todo el resto de su vida y
esas sin sentidos y eso sin saber las
causas de que lo que no está pasando las
encontramos ahí la palin genesa nos
permite volver ahí durante siete años
cientos de personas han he podido he
tenido la privilegiada
han depositado su confianza en mí he
podido ver lo que tenían dentro lo que
tenían dentro eran decisiones
amorosas decisiones amorosas en el
primer los primeros días primeros meses
en esos nueve meses que pasamos en la
barriga de nuestra madre que son
insustituibles y que nos marca cómo son
esas decisiones porque esa decisión y
esa libertad y ese amor es erróneo y se
demuestra como tal en la vida adulta
porque esa primera fase hay varias
razones pero la primera es que en esa
primera fase la nueva persona la nueva
persona es mejor que el entorno la nueva
persona tiene más conocimiento tiene más
amor y más libertad
que el entorno de vivientes adultos que
encuentra a su llegada
hay un sociólogo en neozelandés james
flynn que dice un número no será
exactamente así pero es más o menos cada
10 años aumenta tres puntos el
coeficiente intelectual de las
generaciones o sea que una persona nueva
tiene a día de hoy diez puntos más de
coeficiente intelectual que sus padres y
veinte más que sus abuelos o sabes un
primer dato primero para respetar esa
persona nueva y para entender lo que
está pasando ahí segundo factor que hace
que esa persona tome decisiones libres
erróneas
el nivel lo que pide es esa persona
nueva es amor armonía y que todo el
mundo se lleve bien y quien no haya
malos rollos
entonces cuando llega a este mundo
precisamente lo que se encuentra es lo
contrario el criterio de la nueva
persona es amor si alguien quiere saber
lo que es amor tiene que bajar al nivel
de niño todos los que estamos aquí ha
habido un momento que hemos sido niños
amorosos pero son los primeros momentos
si tú quieres llegar a lo mejor de tu
vida a lo mejor de tu persona tienes que
volver a ese primer momento en que tu
criterio edad de amor para todos
incondicional
donald de aceptación no he visto a
ninguna persona de las que explorado que
hayas dejado de aceptar a sus padres
sean lo que sea el niño acepta pero el
entorno es hostil y el entorno somos
nosotros
tenemos enfrente un niño
que es más inteligente que nosotros
depende si somos padres o abuelos diez o
veinte puntos más y que además sus
criterios de amor cuál es el criterio
del entorno de criterio entorno es un
entorno es un criterio de triunfo de
reconocimiento de acopio de bienes
materiales todo eso a la nueva persona
no le importa
y cuando afronta ese entorno y ve los
y ve los desastres que este criterio
organiza él también se deteriora
entonces tenemos
un tercer criterio y es que la decisión
libre de cada persona es impredecible
impredecible he tratado personas gemelas
y han tenido las mismas vivencias y una
persona elige querer a la madre y otra y
el otro gemelo elige que red al tío o al
abuelo eligen libremente y es
impredecible es impredecible
que por ejemplo pues y es frecuente
relativamente que elija esa nueva
persona a la persona de la familia que
más está para de que más está padeciendo
que más altera o está porque le quiere y
le lanza un cable de amor todos estos
movimientos son los que se dan en la
profundidad de la persona profundidad
que tenemos todos siempre tenemos el
reto de decir nos dedicamos a la
apariencia externa de las personas o nos
dedicamos a la profundidad en la
profundidad donde tenemos lo que
realmente vale tenemos nuestro acto de
ser tenemos nuestras facultades en acto
el resto se da potencia y se irá
desarrollando con el tiempo entonces con
las personas así decidiendo libremente
con una exigencia mayor y con un
criterio exclusivo de amor encontramos
las alteraciones que luego en el futuro
nos van a dar unas dolencias y que para
remediarlas tenemos que volver a revivir
por ejemplo seguro que habéis tenido
toda la experiencia pues una pareja que
que se está mejor están discutiendo con
la voz un poco alta y el niño dice
o ves a separar y sin un niño no que
estamos discutiendo que no tiene nada
que ver con que nos vayamos a separar
pero es el criterio del niño o sea ese
tono de voz
tampoco delicado pero tan normal para
los adultos para el niño es muy lesivo
he tenido una experiencia en un colegio
sistemáticamente he visto 18 niños que
son los 18 niños más problemáticos y
después de acabar la el estudio de las
18 personas los orientadores y los
profesores y yo mismo me quedo asombrado
ninguno de ellos tenía ningún problema
todos ellos estaban alterados por un
problema de un adulto al cual querían y
les ocupaba la cabeza con un déficit de
atención o con una hiperactividad o con
un autismo
con todo esto que les estoy diciendo les
pido a todos ustedes un respeto a las
nuevas personas desde que están en la
barriga de su mamá estas personas son
personas y les pido simplemente que se
dirijan a ellas que las tengan en cuenta
es demasiado frecuente esas
conversaciones en que la persona está
reviviendo una escena en la barriga de
su madre están discutiendo están
hablando y él dice 1.009 dice nadie nada
es demasiado frecuente esas notas
escenas que dices yo estoy en los brazos
de mi madre mi madre mi mamá está
cansada no me puede atender mi padre
quiere jugar conmigo pero juega conmigo
como un animalito ya tenemos que
acostumbrarnos a les pido que se
acostumbre a los niños no verlos cómo
está decía como un animalito sino como
una persona que es mucho más inteligente
que nosotros les pido que los vean a las
nuevas personas como intelectos agentes
con patas buenas noches
[Aplausos]